the mind-blowing second season of the
umbrella academy is loaded with hidden
details comic book easter eggs and a
trail of clues predicting the big
cliffhanger ending
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm revealing everything you
missed in the umbrella academy season 2.
just before we begin i want to thank the
sponsor of this video squarespace more
on why they're a great place to build a
website at the end
spoilers ahead so take care if you're
not all caught up
one of the many great things about
season two is seeing pogo again this
time as a baby and discovering that he
was once a budding astronaut and there
was a little easter egg to the
chimpanzee's time and space
in the scene where five tries to buy
some candy from a vending machine
to the left of the candy that five wants
is another chocolate bar with a slogan
take flight with pogo gogos suggesting
perhaps that after going into space the
astro chimp became something of a
celebrity
at least enough to get a chocolate bar
named after him and take an even closer
look at the candy bar because there's a
secret sparrow symbol hidden
inside one of the letters a sneaky
easter egg to the rival team that the
umbrella gang discover has taken their
place at the academy when they return in
2019.
in fact this secret sparrow is just one
of many clues planted throughout season
2 that hint to the new sparrow academy
in the third episode there's a sparrow
on the bass towel at the hotel where the
handler is staying
and when lila is thinking about what to
eat you can spot a little sparrow on the
hotel menu
and a flock of birds possibly sparrows
form the umbrella symbol for the opening
titles of that episode
in addition to that there's a sparrow on
a calendar at allison and rey's house
and there are a couple of sparrow-like
birds in a picture frame on the wall of
the meeting room where five goes to kill
the commission's board of directors
you can also see a sparrow symbol on the
blackboard inside reginald hargreaves
secret room
and when old man 5 opens his briefcase
just before the kennedy assassination
you can see a sparrow emblem on a paper
just above bonya's book from season one
and then there's a small sparrow on the
killer order that the handler issued for
lila's parents
in the finale you can also spot the new
sparrow academy coat of arms on ben's
jacket
and also on the wall behind hargreaves
some other interesting connections that
certain characters may have with the
sparrow academy are the handler who
wears a bath towel on her head with a
little bird on top
and sissy's son harlan often plays with
a toy bird throughout season two which
we also see him levitating in the finale
this is just a theory but could harlan
grow up to become the father of one of
the sparrow academy team
and is the handler or the commission
involved at all in the formation of the
sparrows
given the sheer number of sparrow clues
throughout season two it's almost as if
the creation of the sparrow academy was
inevitable
the moment the umbrella academy jumped
back in time to the 60s and began
changing the timeline
in season 2 luther struggles with his
situation especially after he falls out
with jack ruby and discovers that his
crush alice and is happily married with
another man
so he resorts to comfort eating as a way
of dealing with his unhappiness
the scenes of luther cooking an enormous
mound of eggs or munching his way
through plates of barbecue
are a hat tip to the second volume of
the comic books in which luther falls
into a depression and ends up becoming
morbidly
obese tom hopper who plays luther told
nerdist that the tv series decided
against using a full-on fat suit for his
character as marvel did that recently in
avengers end game with thor
when luther heads out for a run the show
tips its hat to the training scenes in
the rocky movies where sylvester
stallone runs through the streets in a
grey tracksuit and kids run along with
him
luther's running scene ends rather less
victoriously than rocky's though
as he trips and ends up face down on the
ground after he mistakenly thinks he's
seen alison
the umbrella academy's powers really
level up in season two with klaus
mastering how to manifest spirits in the
real world however comic book klaus
also has the power of levitation and
season two makes a funny reference to
this when we see him floating
miraculously in midair in front of his
cult
the joke of course being that he's
actually being lifted up by the
invisible ben
we get an awesome 5 vs 5 fight scene in
episode 9 when schoolboy 5 and old man 5
are gripped by a homicidal
urge to kill each other due to the
effects of paradox psychosis
the purr tried to outmaneuver each other
using spatial jumps in a very cool scene
appropriately set to the tune of dancing
with myself
the scene is a nod to avengers end game
where captain america traveled back in
time and ended up fighting with his past
self
and there's another homage to captain
america when during the fight schoolboy
5 drops steve rogers iconic line
i can do this all day i can do this all
day yeah i know
i know and of course both scenes are a
wink to fans of the 1960s animated
spider-man cartoon where the real spidey
faces off with the spider-man imposter
a moment that became a hugely popular
meme and was recently given a fresh
twist and spider-man into the
spider-verse
in season two diego's hero complex
really takes over as he becomes obsessed
with trying to save president kennedy
but there was a little detail in the
season's opening scene you might have
missed that sets diego apart from his
siblings
whereas everyone else crashed to the
ground when they dropped down to the sky
in the 60s diego instead managed a
stylish superhero landing
very much in character with his hero
complex superhero landing yeah that's
really hard on your knees the handler
made a surprise return in season two
proving herself an outrageously ruthless
villain and one of the biggest wtf
moments came when she decided to end
aj's attempts to interfere with her
plans once and for all
by grabbing the goldfish and swallowing
him whole this is actually a shout out
to the comics where five took his
revenge on the goldfish
head of the commission carmichael by
eating him alive
in a brief flashback scene where the
handler stamped the kill order for
lila's parents if you look very closely
just above the stamp you can see aj's
full name atlas
jericho carmichael also on the desk next
to the kill order you can just make out
the corner of a receipt from grudy's
donuts
gritties is a donut shop from the first
season where hazel met and fell in love
with agnes
in season two human grace discovers a
hidden room filled
with reginald hargreaves research and on
the blackboard are plans for something
called the televator which is described
as the next great mode of transportation
in the comics the televator is a machine
invented by hargreaves and klaus has one
built to transport him luther
and pogo from vietnam to dallas the
televator easter egg in the tv show
might be a hint that we'll see this
device in a future season
especially given it also made an
appearance on a comic book cover in
season one
and there's an easter egg to another
hargreaves invention from the comics
this time the breakfast cereal clever
crisp which appears on the kitchen table
and elliot's home
another comic book easter egg crops up
when five complains that his siblings
failed to show up for their time jump
back to 2019.
all you had to do was be here didn't
have to fight a giant sea monster no
this is a nod to the comic book short
story but the past ain't through with
you
where the umbrella academy were delayed
on a mission after having to battle a
sea serpent in the pacific ocean
just before the umbrella gang returned
from 1963 to 2019
we see a brief scene of jack ruby
watching a news report about the kennedy
assassination
then there's a very quick shot of him
grabbing a gun a subtle reference to how
in real life ruby fatally shot lee
harvey oswald while he was in dallas
police custody
oswald was a primary suspect in the
kennedy murder investigation at the time
and ruby claimed he shot him
spontaneously and that he was upset over
kennedy's death
there are many conspiracy theories
surrounding the jfk assassination and
the umbrella academy show minds a number
of those to set up various subplots in
season two
for example the umbrella man who the
team mistakenly believe is their father
is a real-life person who was standing
near kennedy's motorcade when the
president was shot
because the real-life umbrella man was
wearing a large raincoat and carrying an
umbrella on a warm sunny day in dallas
some believe he was there to act as a
signal for the assassination to go ahead
something that was also referenced in
the umbrella academy oh he's the
signalman for the whole goddamn thing
the theory was called into question when
louis stephen witt
came forward to state that he was the
umbrella man on the day and that he was
carrying the umbrella to protest the
kennedy family's appeasement policy
towards nazi germany in the 30s
in the show the shadowy majestic 12
organization turns out to be behind
jfk's murder
in real life the majestic 12 are a
purported secret organization whose
existence is popular among ufo
conspiracy theorists although the fbi
and others say the existence of the
secret society as a hoax
among the alleged real-life members of
the group is roscoe h hillenkotter
he's referenced in the show on an
invitation card to the gala at the
mexican consulate
which is where we see the majestic 12
meet for the first time
the tv show plays up the nefarious
nature of the majestic 12 and how they
seem to be secretly influencing events
the sunglasses man often pops up in the
background of various scenes for example
he seems to be on friendly terms with
jack ruby when we see the club owner
briefly talking to him in the first
episode
we okay here could this be the show
suggesting a connection between the
majestic 12 and jack ruby's subsequent
murder of lee harvey oswald
and the same sunglasses man is watching
on during pogo's astronaut training
he's a bit of an enigma and the way he
seems to be constantly smoking reminds
me of the smoking man from the x-files
and the x-files gets his own shout out
when conspiracy theorist elliot
first meets five and asks if ufos and
crop circles are real and five replies
using the famous
tagline from the sci-fi tv series well
the truth is out there
and given elliott's interest in
spaceships and aliens i can't help but
wonder if his character was named after
the little boy elliot who befriended an
extraterrestrial in e.t
even before it's revealed that reginald
hargreaves is an alien in season two's
penultimate episode there are little
hints at his true form
for example diego warns grace about
hargreaves and his nasty squad of lizard
people
and costume designer christopher
hargarden told nerdist that he
specifically gave hargreaves lizard
shoes and more vibrant clothes and his
colleagues as he wanted to indicate
there was something strange about the
guy
and the face mask that hargreaves
removes from his head is also referenced
to the same mask that reveals his alien
origins in the comics
the season finale reveals the apparent
end of the umbrella academy and their
replacement with the sparrow academy
and the episode's title the end of
something is also a clever call back to
the first season when the handler
cryptically explained to five that the
apocalypse wasn't the end of everything
but
just the end of something now you
doubtless noticed the handler's outfits
getting more and more flamboyant as the
season progressed and her power grew
within the commission
but there were some more subtle details
that also mirrored her rise to power
for example in the third episode you can
spot a small red spider brooch on her
handbag
by the ninth episode there's a bigger
spider brooch and it's migrated onto her
outfit
and by the finale it's climbed all the
way up to her hat the spiders seem to
reflect the ever-growing web that the
handler spins in season 2 as her status
rises
and the red sequined shoes that the
camera focuses on when the handler
arrives during the murder of lila's
parents
are a possible allusion to the ruby
slippers from the wizard of oz which
originally belonged to the wicked witch
of the east
the song bibbidi-bobbidi-boo which plays
when the handler returns to the
commission is a subtle reference to
cinderella's fairy godmother
the twist here being that for lila the
handler ends up being a wicked mother to
her who deliberately orchestrated the
murder of her parents
lila's ability to copy or mirror the
umbrella crew's powers is a pretty
awesome reveal in the final episode and
when five
asks her how she can do it she simply
replies oh anything that you can do
i can do better which is a little
reference to the duet of the same name
from the musical annie get your gun
where the two singers compete to outdo
each other performing the same tasks
there's a neat bit of foreshadowing of
harlan's arc when in the opening episode
vonya tells [ __ ] that she and harlan
have been reading james and the giant
peach
in the popular novel by roald dahl a
young boy ends up going on a fantastical
adventure with seven magical bugs
a possible parallel to harlan and the
seven members of the umbrella academy i
know you don't get it but that is an
excellent reference
and after harlem becomes connected to
vanya through the powers that she
transfers to him he seems to have some
foresight or ability to sense the future
in the eighth episode you can see harlan
drawing a picture of somebody flying
above the farmhouse and barn
a foreshadowing of how vonya will later
float out of the barn to attack the
handler's army of commission agents in
the finale
there's been plenty of comparisons
between the umbrella academy and other
popular superhero teams such as the
x-men and doom patrol
with vonya's powerful abilities that
sometimes threaten to rage out of
control often reminding people of jean
grey and dark phoenix
and it feels like there's a gene
greyesque moment in season two when
vonya levitates the water out of the
lake where harlan drowns
ellen page who plays bonya joined the
x-men movies as kitty pride in x-men the
last stand
and in that film when the phoenix force
rages out of control in jean grey she
levitates a wall of water around
alcatraz
and suicidably for a time travel
apocalypse story the umbrella academy
also squeezes in a reference to the
terminator movies when hazel shows up in
the midst of the 1963 doomsday and tells
five if you wanna live come with me
i just love the incredible attention to
detail in the series and all the
creative easter eggs added for the fans
and if you feel inspired by the show's
inventiveness give an outlet to your own
imagination on squarespace a fantastic
platform you can easily use to build
your own
online presence whether you're looking
to start your own blog or podcast or
open an online store
there are tons of amazing ready-made
templates that you can rapidly customize
to fit your requirements
you don't need any technical knowledge
but 24 7 support is always at hand if
you have any questions or need some help
you can also easily connect your site
with social platforms like twitter and
facebook and set up email marketing
campaigns to help you grow and connect
with your visitors
so head on over to squarespace.com
flicks or follow the link in the video
description below where you can try the
platform completely free for 14 days
and when your site is ready to launch
you'll get an extra 10
discount with that link so what other
easter eggs or cool details did you spot
in season two
comment below and if you enjoyed this
video a thumbs up is hugely appreciated
tap left for my full breakdown of who's
behind the sparrow academy and how the
timelines have changed for season three
or tap right for something else you're
sure to like thanks for watching and see
you next time yupikai movie lovers